the news is changing so rapidly every
day it's hard to keep up at the moment
as Co vid cases taper off in countries
like France and Italy they're going down
the number of cases the United States
continues to spike sadly and that's why
the European Union recently announced
Americans are not allowed to travel
there until further notice
we can't go to Europe were banned it's a
very extreme measure I understand it but
it's extreme and this new tourism ad for
the European Union I don't know I didn't
really appreciate it
take a look the European Union is open
for tourism again consider from the
snow-capped Alps to the verdant hills of
Umbria there's so much to see in the EU
but even better here's something you
won't see right now Americans because of
massive Coble outbreaks in the US
Americans are from traveling here which
means you get to experience Europe
without experiencing American tourists
complaining about are very reasonable
portion sizes no Americans making fun of
Dale it's perfectly average science
penis
you won't see American idiots doing this
for these know Americans demanding their
steak tartare cook
well-done or pointing and laughing at
our immortal swimwear to relax and enjoy
America Free Europe filled with busy
cafes and empty McDonald's visit the EU
now quick before they find the vaccine
[Music]